[Musique]
je suis Lionel Vergoz agriculteur à la
solineo sous la ferme la marmandia je
suis installé depuis 2011 où je
travaille avec mon père qui a repris la
suite de mon grand-père
[Musique]
on a une production principale de
fourrage pour les animaux et dans une
optique de diversification en
transformant les produits du jardin donc
on fait du zévis et VIH chez de l'ail du
gingembre donc à utiliser en tartinade
donc condiment à l'assiette de la mousse
de piment donc du piment doux justement
pour tout le monde puisse en profiter en
tortina dans le condiment et également
du piment un peu plus fort et également
des sauces cuisinées des plats typiques
de la Réunion le massalé le cari et le
rougail le produit phare c'est le Davy
c'est celui là qu'on a utilisé en
premier pour commencer la
diversification
et sur la même recette ensuite on a
décliné les mousses de piment
alors le Salon de l'Agriculture pour moi
ce serait une opportunité de rencontrer
des boutiques sur la métropole pour
pouvoir faire connaître mon produit en
métropole et sortir de l'île justement
pour pouvoir rayonner un petit peu en
métropole
[Musique]